people are like oh why she's so hot why
is he with this dumpy guy and then and
then bros would be like oh cause because
he probably has a huge dick funny story
about that me and tiffany had
uh had it with a comedy central party
with uber back together uh to to make
two stops to her place in my place and
then i was like hey tiffany wanna stop
by up here for a drink
okay you know like pretty obvious
and then like we're both pretty drunk
and then there's an in an uber and then
she's like i don't know jimmy word on
the street your dick game weak and i was
like no no no no no who the [ __ ] what
are you talking about man that's not
even true my dick game is great you know
and i was like who was your sources well
i started like arguing with her but
really that was just her testing me you
know i ain't like like i was supposed to
say man [ __ ] that let me show you my
dick game you know but i i didn't
understand the game of that so like i
was flustered yeah because the uber
driver started laughing because she kept
saying like we're on the street jimmy
your dick game weekend and the uber
driver like started chuckling i was like
no no that's not true sir